welcome to nerve a game like truth or
dare - the truth Watchers pay to watch
players play to win cash and glory are
you a watcher or a player are you a
watch or a player are you a watcher
player watch player it's cool right this
looks very sketchy is this legal fee
life just passing you by you need to
take a few risks every once in a while I
do take risks okay you're playing you're
to accept your Derby kiss a stranger for
five [ __ ] just kiss that guy okay okay
bye apparently the Watchers want me to
team up with you I don't think I'd make
a very good partner stay let's see what
else happens okay
you know where I can find this dress
my wallet my clothes everything's gone
oh my stuff has gone too let's go come
on not look we all have a choice
technically it just says we have to
leave the store
big fan
well I'm just doing the wine daddy what
he's kidding dolla dolla bill y'all
no some kid died in Seattle cleaners
what happens if I bail you lose
everything all of our money is missing
we've not what officer what sir I need
help we don't do this
how'd you know mean what the hell is
going on watches they stole our
identities we became prisoners of the
game they we control your life the only
way out is to win
I remember you're my eyes No
players showed us your weapons
blindfolded on the motorcycle
you ready
I remember you're my eyes hold on keep
your eyes open okay okay I know you care
do you guys talk to me maybe left or
right you are in control okay speed up
get there
okay the next Lane is green
I've got this the next light is come on
stay with me what's going on screen
we're doing this
you go
you
welcome to nerd a game like truth or
dare mine is the truth watchers pay to
watch players play to win is this legal
life is passing you by you need to take
a risk once in a while is a stranger for
five seconds
apparently the Watchers want me to team
up with you I stay let's see what else
happens love a
do you know where I can find his trust
look very pretty go come on look we all
have a choice technically it just says
we're free of the store
big fan salad allophilia
well I'm just doing the why and daddy
what he's kidding
have a little bit of Anarchy what hell
is going on watch these dollar
identities Oh sir I need help me don't
do this Italy honestly
rated pg-13 starts to on 27th
yeah so many blessings raining a little
bit
please no fire-breathing dragons or 910
tasteful these gorgeous honestly he's a
nice guy you guys come on you have to
trust me and okay this really great it's
almost done
oh my god this is the greatest portrait
of me on horseback that I've ever done
I'm not kidding what he's kidding don't
listen to him boom I'm done go to that
mirror you celebrate my work welcome to
nerve is stranger for five seconds
apparently the watchers like this
together
I'm just doing the why and daddy what
he's kidding
blindfolded you are in control
rated pg-13 now played welcome to nerve
we are the Watchers we decide your dares
is this legal you think this is just a
game it was the craziest thing I've ever
done this game is sick
we control your life what sir I need
help we don't do this how do you know
any we control new future there is no
sterday we became prisoners of the game
the only way out is to win
butI remember we are always watching
you
oh we're in the elevator ourselves in a
couple get IV bromine so it should
probably cut like dang and we were like
what's going on then we go run through
the bag full of Prada bags that'll be
great we're going to go through the
lobby over there
Oh nervous starting let's nerve like the
truth or dare but for money it's a
stranger for five seconds
who's this legal you need to learn to
take risks every once in a while
the watchers like this together I'm not
that they are double tight do this with
me
what happens if I bail you've been dared
it's gonna be me and you
No rated pg-13 July from seven welcome
to Newark who have chosen player
apparently to watch it like this
together let's get this starter critics
and audiences can't get enough of nerve
are so thanks
it's amazing I'm laughing cause it's
good and thrilling we dare you to not
look away
remember you're my eyes
the main thing I've ever done you were
incredible rated pg-13 now play
welcome to nerve nerve is like truth or
dare
gets a 60 miles per hour - the truth
blindfolded Watchers paid to watch
players play to win know that some kid
died playing there what hell is going on
you can't stop playing now we control
your life
the only way out is to win curve rated
PG 30 July 27th do you have the nerve a
game like truth or dare
is this legal it's cool
it's the easiest way to win cash or
glory this game is sick if you have the
nerve play the game play the game
three so nerve in Buddha's July 27
welcome to nerve again like truth or
dare mine is the truth
watchers pay to watch players play to
win kiss a stranger for five seconds
apparently the Watchers want me to team
up with you
big fan dala dala billy oh well though
I'm just doing the why and daddy what
he's kidding
it's not a little pin anarchie what the
hell is going on only way out is to win
starts July 27th welcome to nerve nerve
is like truth or dare - the truth
Watchers paid to watch players win cash
and glory are you a watcher or a player
are you a watcher or a player are you
launcher or higher
are you watch or a player scheme is sick
you have chosen player rated pg-13
good luck player I signed up for nerve
you signed up as a player is it so hard
to believe
welcome to nerve you have chosen player
watchers decide your dares it's a
stranger for five thank you apparently
the watchers like us together be it in
the top ten what do they know you're
afraid of heights I know all the
information about you
where are does the only way out is to
win come on I need you rated pg-13
notes July 27th you're playing nerve
what you've been dared do you accept
your dare
though some kids want to take a ride
go through play to him
breathe
say yes nerve rated pg-13 July 27th life
is passing you find you need to take a
risk once in a while I do take risks
you're playing here
it's like truth or dare but for money
kiss a stranger for five seconds
apparently the watchers want me to team
up with you so I'm not that they are
devil tight lovey
that's the greatest thing I've ever done
you were incredible
you guys are so famous big fan
weighted pg-13 July 27 for me life is
passing you by you need to take a few
risks every once in a while I do take
risks okay you're playing you're to
accept your Derby